اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه مفصله من العربيه نبداها
كالعاده بالعناوين
طبعا
مباحثات مرتقبه في جده اليوم بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع بمبادره سعوديه
امريكيه
نقابه اطباء السودان تحذر من انقطاع
الادويه وصحه العالميه ترسل اولى الشحنات
الطبيه الى بورتسودان
قائد فاجنر يتحدث عن تقدم في بخموت ويقول
بقي القليل للسيطره عليها قبل التاسع من
مايو
فاحتفال هو الاكبر من 70 عاما بريطانيا
تستعد لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث قص
اجراءات امنيه مشدده
حياكم الله تتجه الانظار الى مدينه جده
التي ينتظر ان تحتضن اليوم باحثات بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع بمبادره سعوديه امريكيه وقد اكدت
مصادر العربيه ان وفد من الجيش السوداني
واخر من قوه الدعم السريع غادر الى مدينه
جده لبدء المفاوضات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع واشارت مصادر العربيه الى ان وفد
الجيش يمثله ثلاثه ضباط وسفير اما وفد
الدعم فيمثله ثلاثه ضباط فقط فيما اكد
الجيش السوداني ان وفده الذي غادر الى جده
سيناقش التفاصيل الخاصه بالهدنه التي يجري
تجديدها بغرض تامين وتهيئه الظروف
المناسبه للتعامل مع الجوانب الانسانيه
ورحبت المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ببدء المحادثات الاوليه
بين ممثلي القوات المسلحه السودانيه وممثل
قوات الدعم السريع في مدينه جده قال بيان
السعوديون امريكي المشترك ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحثان كلا الطرفين على استشعار
مسؤولياتهما تجاه الشعب السوداني
والانخراط الجاد في هذه المحادثات ورسم
خارطه طريق للمباحثات لوقف العمليات
العسكريه وشدد البيان على ضروره انهاء
الصراع وتجنيب الشعب السوداني التعرض
للمزيد من المعاناه وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه للمناطق المتضرره واضاف البيان
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه توشيدان بجهود كافه
الدول والمنظمات التي ابدت تاييدها لعقد
هذه المباحثات بما في ذلك مجموعه دول
الرباعيه وجامعه الدول العربيه والاليه
الثلاثيه كما حدث السعوديه والولايات
المتحده على استمرار بدر الجهود الدوليه
المنسقه لمفاوضات واسعه تشارك فيها كل
الاحزاب السودانيه
هذا وكان وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان تلقى اتصالا هاتفيا من
نظيره الامريكي بحث خلاله مستجدات الوضع
في السودان اكدت الخارجيه السعوديه ان
الامير فيصل بن فرحان وبلينكن اكدائها
اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكري في السودان
وانهاء العنف وبحثاه ايضا مستجدات
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه التي ستستضيف
ممثلين عن الطرفين في جده التي تهدف
لتهيئه ارضيه لازمه او ارضيه لازمه للحوار
وخط التوترات
وقد رحبت القوه المدنيه السودانيه الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي بالمباحثات المزمعه
عقدها بين طرفي النزاع في جده السعوديه
بمبادره سعوديه امريكيه وقالت القوه
المدنيه في بيان لها انها تامل ان تقود
هذه المباحثات لوقف تام للقتال ومعالجه
للاوضاع الانسانيه بما يمهد الطريقه لحل
سلمي سياسي مستدام واعتبرت ان هذه
المباحثات تشكل خطوه اولى لوقف الانهيار
المتسارع الذي شهده السودان منذ اندلاع
الحرب منتصف ابريل الماضي مشيره الى انها
تامل من قياده القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع قرارات الشجاعه تنتصر لصوت الحكمه
وتوقف القتال وتنهي المعاناه التي يعيشها
الشعب جراء الحرب كما تقدمت القوه المدنيه
بالشكر لحكومتي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه على جهودهما
من اجل الترتيب لهذه المباحثات والوصول
لصيغه تنهي الحرب
وتحل السلام
وفي اليوم الثاني والعشرين للحرب الدائره
في السودان بين القوات الجيش والدعم
السريع سمعت في ساعات الصباح الاولى اصوات
اشتباكات متقطعه بالاسلحه الثقيله ودوي
الانفجارات لقصف الطيران الحربي في
العاصمه الخرطوم فيما تحلق طائرات حربيه
في سماء المدن الثلاث للعاصمه بحري وام
درمان والخرطوم
ينضم الينا من هناك صحفي عبد القادر باكاش
عبد القادر مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشر عبد
القادر دعني يعني ابدا معك في اهم الارقام
اهم المعلومات ايضا حتى اللحظه نحن ندخل
الاسبوع الرابع في هذه
الاشتباكات وربما الاسبوع الثالث من
عمليات الاجلاء خصوصا من بورت السودان ما
هي ابرز اهم المعلومات حتى اللحظه
المتوفر حتى لا انا لجلاع يستمر في مدينه
بورسودان لليوم الرابع عشر العام
تملاه اغلب الرايه الدول الاجنبيه من
منسوبيه المنظمات الامميه واعضاء البعثات
الدوليه وكذلك عدد كبير من رعايه الدول
العربيه تم اجلائهم
والان تبقت فقط
بقايا من الاخوه السوريين واليمنيين في
مدينه بورسودان تجد
الترتيباتهم الطائرات قطنيه
وجهود سعوديه ان شاء الله بالتنسيق مع
الحكومه اليمنيه لاجلاء نحو ثلاثه الاف
يمني مقيمون الان في مدينه مرسولان بصوره
عامه الان الانذار تتجه نحو المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي ستنطلق لان الاعمال
معقوده بان تكون هذه المحادثات تفضي الى
استقرار يؤدي الى استمرار في السودان بعد
ان اصابها الشلل بسبب يعني الان اغلب
السودانيين لم يشرفوا اول الحكومه
السودانيه بصوره عامه جميع الموظفين وقاده
النظامين وغيرهم جميعهم لم يصرفوا رواتبهم
للتعدل النظام المالي السوداني نتيجه
للتوقف العاصمه تماما من
من اداء مهامها الحكوميه الان البحر
الاحمر يعني
لها جهود في الحكومه المركزيه لها جهود في
البحر الاحمر لنقل بعض المؤسسات ذات
الاساسيه العاليه وصل الان اداء اللجنه
العليا
الحالات الانسانيه للاشراف على الجسر
الجوي الذي بدا يرد من بعض الدول العربيه
التي قامت بالسالمساعدات انسانيه طبيه
وانسانيه الان لمدينه بورسودان تشرف عليها
اللجنه الحكوميه لتوزيعها على عدد من
المناطق المتاثره بالحرب الان مدينه
بورسلان بشوره عامه وشرق السودان لم يشهد
اي قتال وهو يعتبر من اعمل المناطق التي
تجري ابرها عمليات الاجلاء والان الاجلاء
مستمر تماما وبصوره مصابه كذلك تم فتح
مكتب لوزاره الخارجيه وعدد من السفارات
ايضا اعلنت لمكانت في بورسلان ومنظمات
امنيه ايضا افتتحت مقاتل في بورسلان لمت
وضع الانساني الان الناس تنتظر ماذا الى
ماذا تفضي المحادثات التي ستمتلك في جده
بعد قليل حتى يتمكن من ارسال هذه
المساعدات لطرق امنه الى المناطق المستحقه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من بورسودان ضم الينا
الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش
اذا عقب الاعلان عن هدره جديده في السودان
تامت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه قوات الدعم
السريع بخلق الهدنه وارتكاب انتهاكات عده
اقلت الخارجيه السودانيه في بيان الله ان
قوات الدعم السريع مستمره في خرق الهدنه
وانها استهدفت المرافق الصحيه والمياه
وقطاع الكهرباء دون مراعاه للقانون الدولي
كما لجات الى استهداف قطاع الكهرباء
بتعطيل المحطه المركزيه للتحكم وفقا
للبيان وادعت الخارجيه السودانيه المجتمع
الدولي لادانه الافعال الشنيعه التي تقوم
بها قوه الدعم السريع
قال سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان عطيه عبد
الله لقناه العربيه ان 12000 مريض في
مستشفيات الدوله معرضون للموت بسبب نقص
الادويه والمعدات الطبيه اللازمه لعلاجهم
مؤكدا ان الطاقم الصحي اعيا ان يداوي
العديد من الاصابات والمرضى فلقوا حتفهم
داخل المستشفيات بسبب انقطاع الادويه
وضيفا ان 13 شخصا من الكوادر الطبيه قتلوا
منذ بدء الصراع قبل نحو اثنين وعشرين يوما
من ولايه ميريلاندا الامريكيه ينضم الينا
الباحث السياسي الدكتور صلاح البشير دكتور
صلاح مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره الدكتور
صلاح المباحثات بين طرفي النزاع ستنطلق
اليوم في مدينه جده السعوديه على ماذا
يمكن التعويل فيها برايك
مرحبا بك وبالعربيه ومنسوبيها وبكل
مشاهديها في كل العالم اهلا بك الحقيقه
اولا دعنا نشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ملكا وحكومه وشعبا على هذه المبادره التي
ساندتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وساندها كل
شرفاء العالم حتى يقف سيل الدم في
الخرطوم الحبيبه وايضا
تقدم او نجد وسيله
لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه خاصه وان
الحرب الان دخلت في اسبوعها الرابع
دون توقف ودون ان يكون هنالك استعداد كاف
لهذه الحرب من قبل المواطنين
كثير من الاعمال
يعني من ومعموله من هذه المباحثات في ان
تصل مبدا
بهدنه طويله المدى يلتزم فيها الطرفان
بكل ما يجب عليه ان يلتزم به واهم شيء
يلتزم به هو ان لا يكون هنالك حراك عسكري
داخل او اثناء هذه الفطره حتى يتمكن الناس
من اداء اعمالهم وايضا من الوصول الى
المستشفيات وغيره
المتوقع دكتور من من هذه المحادثات هل هي
تثبيت لهدنه قائمه ام محاوله حتى الاطراف
على وقف تام لاطلاق النار والجلوس على
طاوله الحوار بين كل اطراف العوده الى
العمليه السياسيه كذلك ايضا بالنظر الى ما
تم التوقيع عليه في الاتفاق الاطاري بين
كل الاطراف
مشكله هذه الهدنه انه الجميع الاطراف
الموجوده فيها تدخل باهداف مختلفه
القائمان على هذه الهدنه
ينتظران من
المتفاودين ان
يجلسا من اجل الشعب السوداني وان يا صلاح
الى وقف تامله اطلاق النار ثم معالجه
المشاكل العالقه بينهم لكن حينما تسمع
السعاده السفير دفع الله الحاج مبعوث
البرهان
الى هذه المباحثات تدرك ان
الوفد القوات المسلحه او وفد الحكومه
ذاهب لمهمه واحده وهي
الحصول على
خذنا طويله المدى يمكن من خلالها ان تتم
بعض الامور الخاصه بالمعاملات الانسانيه
بينما يرجو
الجانب الاخر اللي هو المتمرد
يرى ان هذه الحنه ستسمح له
باستعاده الانفاس وغيره وبالتالي اذا لم
توحد هذه الاهداف
مع بعضها البعض لن تصل لن يصل الداعون
اليها
لما يريدون اشكرك جزيل الشكر من ولايه
ميريلاندا الامريكيه الباحث السياسيه
الدكتور صلاح البشير
اذا تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه في السودان
خاصه في ولايه دارفور حيث السكان بين
كارثه الحرب وتناحر القبائل كل هذا القى
بظلاله مؤخرا على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه بعد
عمليات نهب وسرقه شهدتها دارفور نتابع
جلي هنا حرب شلت الاسواق وقتلت الروح فيها
لكن روح التجاره لا تموت افترش اصحاب
المحلات ما تبقى من صالح بضاعتهم هنا
اختلقوا سوقا اخر فلا بد للرزق ان يسري
وان كان في خضم الحرب
الان نحن رجعنا عشان نقدر نطلع يومياتنا
باي صوره من الصور
مدينه الجنينه عانت الامرين حرب من جهه
واشتباكات بين القبائل ايضا عمليات نهب
وحرق افقدت التجار هنا باب رزقهم الوحيد
للاولاه هنا النزاعات بتختلف ماذا الاماكن
الثانيه لانه بتاخد طابع اخر تابع
او تابع قبل تقدر تقول عليه مواطن هنا
عالم وانا كبير وفقدت عدد كبير من الارواح
خسرت المدينه من ابنائها ما يقاربون 100
شخص على الاقل احداث تتوالى فيها الخسارات
وسطى مخاوفه من عنف قد يستمر طويلا غيداء
السالم العربيه
نشرت قوات الدعم السريع فيديو تقول فيه
انها بسطت سيطرتها على منطقه الخرطوم بحري
قبل ان ينفي الجيش السوداني على الفور
سيطره الدعم على هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله ونتمنى لكل حاجه تمشي بخير
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
قال مراسل العربيه ان الرحلات الجويه من
مطار جده الى مطار مدينه بورتسودان
السودانيه استانفت مجددا عبر شركه الطيران
السودانيه تاركو ذهبا وايابا وذلك بعد ان
توقفت الحركه الجويه من مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي بجده الى المطارات
السودانيه منتصف ابريل الماضي واشار مراسل
العربيه الى ان اول رحله انطلقت من بورت
السودان اليوم السبت وعلى متنها 120 راكبا
حيث ستستمر عمليات السفر حتى نهايه الشهر
الحالي باربع رحلات يوميا اذ ستكون هذه
الفتره مخصصه لمغادره المعتمرين من جده
الى بورتسودان في حين ستكون الرحله
القادمه من بورتسودان الى جده لاصحاب
الاقامات والزياره
مع تواصل الاقتتال بين طرفي النزاع في
السودان تزداد معاناه المدنيين مع شح
المواد الغذائيه والطبيه في حين تقطعت
السبل بالكثير منهم بعدما فروا من مناطق
الاشتباكات في محاوله للخروج خارج البلاد
من الحروبات دي كنا نقعد نموت في الحرب
احسن
طلعنا على اساس مخرج ما في مخرج
وبعدين يعني
الناس قاعد تقدم حل الاشكاليه بواجهوا
الجميع العالميه
جديده يعني في ناس يومين ثلاثه اربعه يوم
البحر لما تجي بيشيل الجوازات يخطبوها
الناس
في صعوبه شويه في انه في عمليه البلاد
اربعه ايام على حسب
على حسب اصلا هم زياره اقامه على حسب
في ناس بيكونوا يعني الام وقيمه والاولاد
زياره عشان كده بكون متعطلين شو كان ما
قاعدين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات